hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 55 of game
programming so today I sort of left you
guys on a cliffhanger in the last
episode as you people are calling it I
didn't actually quite finish the episode
I guess well I did but um I said left us
as at this and there wasn't really the
map wasn't really showing up the map
that we actually made wasn't really
showing up and again if you missed last
week's not last weeks if you miss the
last episode then I'm be sure to to find
it I'm just thinking of a way to like
link you guys to it but there's there's
really no way just go to my channel and
find it and watch it because um
otherwise you have no idea what I'm
talking about but anyway last episode we
we made a map and we ended up without
the map so there are there are a few
crucial problems in the code right now
so first of all I don't know if you guys
picked up on this I read some of the
comments model but um I'm not sure if
you guys picked up on this but you can
see that we've got this generated level
method that actually you know converts
pixels into tiles but hey like it's not
really actually being cold anyway so if
you if you right click on generate level
hit references and then workspace then
over here you'll find that the only
place that is being referenced is a
level over here so if it'll click you'll
see that the only place is being called
at is this level constructor now
remember that's the level constructor we
use when we generate a random level not
when we generate a level from a file
which is this constructor so very
important that you copy and paste that
into here so that off we low level we do
generator just as we did with the spawn
level service so sorry with the random
level so this actual generate level
method actually you know bronzed and
generates our level very important stuff
the other thing well there's actually
quite a lot more but uh the other thing
is over here we've got this is sort of
this system that deals with um with
handling like void tiles and that's not
exactly the right way to do it it is
anyway to do it but it's a
so first of all let's isolate this by
itself the way that I prefer to do it is
actually this way so instead of doing
this I'd rather just calculate and
basically say that if we're out of
bounds of here right so in other words
if X plus y times 16 is less than 0 or
if X plus y times 16 is greater than or
equal to 256 and the reason is 256 is
because 16 times 16 is turning if you
say so you could do it that way right if
you really wanted to but um yeah but
turn this is here because I know what 16
times 16 is so yeah we'll do that right
and the other thing is that's all cool
like will render the water but will you
know it'll kind of run this method right
off - after we finish this if statement
we still kind of run this method and if
it is less than 0 or greater than or
equal to n equal to 250 256 what's
actually going to happen is as soon as
it tries to run this is going to crash
with an array index out of bounds
exception if that statement is true so
what we need to do is simply continue
and continue will actually make sure
that we sort of skip the loop and do not
run this code don't run the remainder of
the code in the loop so let's take a
look at what it looks like now okay so
we get crashed straight away and the
reason we go crash is this probably
won't be a nullpointerexception I
actually didn't hit the bug but um yes
yeah we go non pointer exception now
that's kind of obvious
and the reason with a null pointer
exception is because it happened at this
line and the other thing that can cause
a null pointer exception here is loves -
leveled up pixels so because it's an
arranger I can pretty much did u s--
straightaway to juice that's interesting
what isn't it anyway um I can deduce
straight away that level pixels just
hasn't been instantiated kind of like
tiles has but this hasn't so let's make
right off the tiles let's make level
pixels that you can see new int width
times height then set let's run this
code again and we get another crash this
time we've got a nullpointerexception
for the time this is fun isn't it this
is this is real debugging right here
running your code every time
just basically going and like yeah
this'll totally work I'll just run the
code and see what happens
ha I usually don't car like this but um
you know certainly it does help so na
pointer exception here looks like
something to do with tiles is wrong so
if I run it again and we'll get to this
not one exception that happens so all of
this is equal to null all right and this
is a bit this is a bit of a problem
right because tiles isn't equal to null
the stuff inside tiles is equal to null
right and that's that what that means is
that whatever tiles is being equal to so
in other words the only place where we
actually set the value of over tile in
in the tiles in the tiles array yeah um
the only time where we actually assign a
value to each of the tiles in the tiles
array is over here in generate level so
what that means is none of these
statements are true well none of them
might be a bit of a stretch but it does
look like none of them because every
single looks like every single thing
here is equal to null so what that means
you may want two things first of all
make it mean that the de level file just
isn't found but obviously it is
otherwise we would actually throw an
exception here so the file exists it can
read the file something's wrong with our
color coding that would be my best bet
here that would be my um my expert
opinion so let's open paint.net and
let's have a look that we haven't
actually screw up the color so the first
one is tell the grass right so there's
probably better way to do this the
better way to do this is probably be to
actually um open up our
actual level file sir right click open
with Internet all right here we go
but I've opened our level file here zoom
in really far so first off we the grass
color right let's just grab the
eyedropper tool and click and now now we
see what color it is so look at 0 0 F F
0 0 we've actually written F F Series
here let's replace that now one other
thing that we need to do is actually add
an F F at the front and that is to
handle the Alpha Channel because that's
sort of how buffered image in Java
handles low arm handles um colors so in
other words you actually saw that when
we were running when we were rendering
the play if I open the screen class and
we were we go to the render player
method then you'll actually see that we
do the same thing here the color equals
pink and that is actually pink remember
but we did we did add an FF out the
front to fill up the Alpha Channel
because otherwise the Alpha channel you
know isn't really correct the Alpha to
treat status the Alpha Channel and then
that that is the remainder of the color
and that just does not work so yeah make
sure you put a 0 0 FF 0 is a restaurant
now with you people wandering this what
the difference between this and this is
right there is no difference between
these two right that again that is
exactly the same thing as saying for
example if I was to say what's the
difference between 256 and 0 to 256 or 0
0 256 right they're both they're
actually equal to each other right but
the thing is when you put a value out
the front suddenly it makes the
difference so it's the same thing as if
I was to say is there a difference
between 222 to 256 or 2 to 0 0 to 50
says suddenly these zeros actually mean
something well it's the same same thing
here all right
so if we would just do if there wasn't
an alpha channel that would be the same
as that right but since we need to add
an alpha channel we also need to add
that to make sure that we are actually
not roaring any red pixels so that is
that is
cool story bro right there so we should
probably do the rest of things so flower
I think is this yellow thing which is F
bushes this again right board is that an
FF at the front and I can assume that
same thing with the rock right 7 f 7 F 0
0 with F filled up alpha channel at the
front which means that it's completely
opaque right FF is the maximal value
which is equal to 215 256 and
well yeah max value means that it's
completely opaque right zero good mean
is completely transparent so like 0%
opacity FF means that it's fully opaque
or 100% opacity so yeah and we'll check
that yep that is 7 f 7 f 0 0 and they
have at the front and we've suddenly got
a color with an alpha channel so let's
take a look at running that whoa check
that out we've got a map so if we
actually look at the map we see that in
the level file we sort of draw a bit of
the thing that with its flowers in the
middle two rocks on the sides let's take
a look here and check that out
still running it like three and a half
thousand frames per second and we've got
the two little rocks and we've got the
files in the middle so yeah check that
out it's pretty sick ok now we do get
this wrapping here you can see that it's
sort of wrapping it's actually going up
one as well that's just um that's just
you know some coding issues I guess but
know that that's just sort of how it's
working right now how that's how it's
set up
I just wanted to show you guys this
technique of doing a level just um just
cuz you know I guess this show is sort
of about learning and and yeah so you
guys should know all the methods I guess
so this is one of the methods and it's
not it's not I wouldn't I would never
use it to be honest I'm just gonna be
straightforward here I would never use
this method which is the method of
actually converting pixels and tiles
more on
converting thistles into tiles right and
then finally you know and doing this
thing like it's messy in my opinion I
arrived I would rather use to get tile
method so that's what we're gonna do
next episode we're gonna talk about
getting into the get tile method
actually um retrieving files and drawing
them that way but that is one way to do
it so now you guys should be filled with
knowledge and yeah basically so well
it's one of the way one of the reasons I
actually like to do this is because a
lot of you guys like to read source code
mother from other games and you might
not understand what they're doing here
if your song exactly the same as my code
here so that is one other way that
people can possibly do it obviously
there are like a hundred ways probably
to draw tiles but hey that's a pretty
common one as well so anyway I hope you
enjoy this episode of game programming
if you do the you know what let's go
over 200 likes this time we've hit a
hundred in like two hours last time so
that's um let's hit lets hit 200 now so
hit that like button and let's let's
rage 200 likes
let guys
you